I said at the end of the NFL Network
coverage to my three guys to my left
charles davis daniel jeremiah and mike
Mayock who wants to call in on Monday I
got I got Mayock looking over his
shoulder saying he's golfing
I got Daniel Jeremiah saying hey path to
the draft returns Monday and I got one
guy saying I'll do anything for you I
love you Charles Davis I love you more
rich you're my quarterback you're my
defensive back and out of the three of
us yes I was really the only one who had
nothing to do Mike Mike Mike Snider's
playing you know he's not like just
playing golf I know he might might get a
big-time offering so yeah a little hard
I've seen they're going looked at my
phone anybody off no no rich I'll do it
what leaps out to you Charles I'll go
macro here what leaps out to you from
the draft well of course you know we'll
start with the quarterbacks very quickly
what you just said before I came on as
perfect as far as I'm concerned all
right let's see how it plays out and all
the Cleveland fans that are actually
freaking out that they didn't take
someone else let it play out but
remember they put their conviction in
this kid at all this time they decided
to go in that direction and I've seen
the explanation for what they did it for
why they took Ward because they think a
cover guys more viable because the
quarterback throws the ball faster and
ever it does and guys don't get home
etcetera etcetera that's big for all the
other teams that were making moves
I loved how Indianapolis addressed the
fact that Andrew Luck is coming back
from injury if we want to be good we got
to protect him and they go big with guys
right out of the gate I think that in
looking at this thing and people keep
talk about how character matters and lot
of times we roll our eyes and go I will
draft anybody there are a lot of really
talented kids that did not get drafted
that I will guarantee is strictly
because teams thought that character
issues were there so the draft will play
itself out we'll look back in a few
years and as you said if you draft
Jonathan Ogden and Ray Lewis you won
that draft it's that simple and we don't
know who won it yet but the last thing I
will say is every time Seattle has been
knocked about their draft along the way
how many
we look back later and going well they
know they're talking about had a method
to their madness I know they were the
kings of day three four for many many a
moon and then they finally did go at a
cold went with Jamar Code Jones out of
the Ohio State so they got and and then
will DISA the tight end and in day three
Mayock said that's as good as they can
get to block it helping protect Russell
Wilson without getting an offensive
lineman when when it all came down to it
though which is the tea meant that you
spotlighted on day three it all meshes
together when you were asked which team
did you like and the drafter wanted to
point out I really like Chicago right
what do you like about the Bears well
you get your your symbol of the city and
roe kwan smith the city of broad
shoulders right rich yeah from bill
george to Dick Butkus to Mike Singletary
to Brian Urlacher they expect this kid
to be the next one he won't fit them in
stature but the way the games played now
he'll play in the middle and he'll play
well the Senator James Daniels gives
them flexibility where they gonna do
with Cody white hair but no matter what
that triple is with him white hair in
Kyle long that helps Mitchell true
Biscay wide receiver from Memphis State
Anthony Miller another target now for
him and a slot receiver so you can get
it to him quicker balls out of his hands
that helps a young quarterback
I just thought through and through they
got value in the fifth round to me and
Bilal Nichols the defensive end from
Delaware all in all I just liked what
they did and you know who else I like
and it's funny because John Robinson the
GM at Tennessee mmm-hmm I think
continues to do a terrific job and to me
has since the beginning getting Rashad
Evans the line back from Alabama he'll
get he'll be next to Wesley Woodyard who
is as good a person as there is in the
league as good a role model mentor
leader that Evans can draft off of early
and then take over that role as the
middle of the defense in that leader
right out of the gate plus he's very
talented and we all thought that they
needed a pass rusher in the first round
end up getting Harold Landry in the
second I thought you know and then they
made the move with the with with the
draft choices I just like what they did
right up there at the top I'm not as
over-the-top about Luke Falk as other
people are but I do think getting him in
the sixth is a
good deal because I think most people
thought he'd go in the third or the
fourth yeah and it's funny we had Trent
Dilfer here a couple weeks ago saying
Luke Falk is as close to somebody coming
out of college looking like Brady as
there is and might be a perfect fit for
New England for them to take and sure
enough Luke Falk goes in pick 199 in the
Brady spot for my kraebel that was a
pretty neat third day moment right there
and yeah and who knows he might turn
into like a Jimmy G type that that
Tennessee might be able to flip later on
because obviously they got their guy at
the quarterback spot for years to come
work which surprised you more that they
didn't go for a quarterback in the stuff
in this draft I mean I know New England
took one really late with Danny Etling
the Chargers didn't take one at all I
mean which which team do you think
should have taken one or you thought
were going to take one that didn't I
thought the Chargers were going to rich
and you know they haven't draft over
this 2013 and you know they keep getting
you know they keep going with Phillip
and he has been extremely durable hasn't
he
but at the same time who's next in the
in the hopper and I don't think they
have that person and I thought that they
would do that I didn't think they'd
trade up in the first round to do it but
I thought they might be one of the first
teams to jump in the second round and
kind of look at a Kyle well you know
look at a law letter right you know
eventually maybe in the third of my
quite someone like that and they just
didn't make that move at all so that was
the one that surprised me more than New
England we talked about it you know on
Saturday
I'm as convinced as I was on Saturday
know England doesn't put a ton of
capital into a backup quarterback Jimmy
G is as high as they went and I still a
little bit befuddled that he's not in
New England yeah okay I'm still a little
bit like but that was the guy okay all
right so he's gone but Brian Hoyer
undrafted free agent Matt Cassel played
tight end for a while at USC no one
really saw that coming he's had a heck
of a career considering where he came
from they did draft what Ryan Mallett
you know wait year many years ago and
found out that that wasn't going to work
but they don't they're to put a ton of
capital into that backup quarterback so
Danny Etling surprised the heck out of
all of us being the name pulled but
doesn't that feel like a very New
England thing to do yeah and then and
the Dolphins didn't take quarterback
either but the one that surprised about
that rich only because once they
probably couldn't get the one they
wanted I think they were like yeah well
we're not going in that dress it was the
one they think they wanted I think that
at that number if they couldn't make a
move and get up there I felt like Josh
Allen would be that guy that was the
sense that I had and if you look at what
Adam has worked with and the types of
throwers he's worked with he could get
the most out of Jay Cutler
big arm guy right Peyton's big strong
less strapping lad before he get hurt
and before and you remember before he
got hurt his last couple of years before
he hurt his thigh rich wasn't Payton
just off the charts mm-hmm I mean we're
looking at going oh my god and then when
that when the injury happened he wasn't
the same after that but still I mean
he's used to those types of guys
Tannehill though I know he likes a lot
so it was gonna take the right guy for
him to go get that and deal with a
quarterback room Ray's got to deal with
that again yeah and they got goose icky
and balázs tied in and running back that
I I think are gonna they need a little
bit more dynamic play in an offense
having lost Jarvis Landry Kenyan Drake
to me though is going to be spectacular
this year those are some interesting
selections when do you think Lamar
Jackson gets on the field Charles and
that was it that was a lively debate
debate Mike and I what by the way what's
it like what's it like to sit in between
Mike and I when we go out it like that
Israel it's like it's like the finals at
Wimbledon we're sitting in the Royal Box
am I the Federer my center am I making
any shot in my bag you are you're
whatever shot you want to pull out you
can pull out and I know we're being
somewhat facetious but I want to say
this seriously with Daniel and I are
sitting there and that's going on and
I'm joking that it's like Wimbledon
we've got our coat and tie on we're in
the Royal Box for watching every shot or
eyes are going back and forth but the
thing for people to understand and I
know it's hard because some of these
conversations get to be kind of tough is
that you're going your job is to
challenge all of us and you do it
extremely well and you also bring a
perspective of you do realize people are
asking these questions people are
talking about this this isn't just
something that we're just throwing out
there we can joke about it be
Sports Talk Radio but like you heard us
at the end of it Daniel and I had talked
about it just me and him about the idea
of what's gone because the year before
when Chicago made the move to go up for
Mitchell true Biscay Mike Glennon was at
their draft party and I know for a fact
that people inside the Chicago Bears
draft room we're diving for the phone
trying to find Mike Glennon to say hey
somebody get him and let him know what's
about to go down so he doesn't walk into
an ambush because it's a tough situation
and look if Joe Flacco doesn't want to
talk about that's entirely up to Flacco
I know you weren't disputing it Mike was
saying he doesn't need to talk I get all
that but the idea that he's gonna be the
draft part and not get asked about it of
course he is that's what happens that's
why Daniel and I have joked at the end
and said if I'm a quarterback I don't go
to a draft party because you ever know
what your team's going to do and we can
joke and laugh but that's a legit
question and for everyone out there can
hear my voice Mike knows this everybody
thinks that Mike and rich are going into
the steel cage and gonna throw down the
respect factor between you two is off
the charts but because of that respect
factor that's how you can challenge each
other and that's what comes out of it
and I think that it's it's better for
everyone yeah and you know the question
that this was all about was about you
know obviously whether Flacco was gonna
answer a question placed him about hey
Lamar's here and he obviously doesn't
want to talk about it because this year
this year either Lamar Jackson's gonna
take his gig yep or or or or the this is
the best case scenario for Flacco is
that Lamar Jackson has a package and the
package is not him split outlawed or in
a slot or behind Flacco it's it's Flacco
going out wide like Cutler smoke him if
he got him out there and try to make it
seem like you're in the route or removed
from the field entirely I think those
are the two choices with with the Ravens
correct I don't disagree at all and
their staff has had experience doing the
exact things that you've talked about
about being you know working those extra
packages getting people on the field you
know I'm the lone skip
ComNet I say loan right I did voice that
on Saturday I'm not crazy about those
things I think did a lot of times with
your offense you've got to be very
careful now it works have we've seen it
work I've also seen it bogged down
offenses you know it got a package let's
get him in the game let's go go go go go
I still remember and this is an exact
apples-to-apples but I wish I I wish
people could I wish I could have gotten
it out in time you remember that Houston
Houston Texans playoff game a couple
years ago at home offense against Kansas
City and it was early in the game
they're down inside I think the five or
the ten and they go with that wild
package where JJ Watt is taking the snap
you remember that one mm-hmm and I'm
screaming at the television
are you nuts why now momentum is going
well for you you've run your plays this
is too much and what happened balls
loose here we go that's not what he does
overall I've kept very careful I just
don't like doing that again not apples
to apples because not a quarterback but
I think that sometimes we get an
over-reliance on we have to have him on
the field we have to do it I say let it
be a little bit more organic but I'm the
old curmudgeon with that which is why
Daniel Jeremiah said he's looking
forward to the preseason schedule
because this is all gonna have to be
worked out in the full view of all 32
teams and everybody who is evaluating
this that's a fascinating story line to
come out of the draft Charles I love you
thanks for calling in it was just
another stellar draft with you DJ Mike
and the whole crew in the truck and all
around it was awesome hey thanks for
having me and remember this with
Baltimore remember how Joe Flacco got
his job to start the opener tonsilitis
with Troy Smith he wasn't supposed to
start got the job and they took off and
ran with it
so serendipity might kick in too we
never know so basically the moral of the
story is if don't getting thick if you
think hold on now don't step further if
you think you have a future quarterback
in the NFL remove his tonsils
I don't know don't go to the draft party
take yeah take care of Charles [ __ ]
that's it thank you the one and only
Charles Davis at CFD 22 the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience